OPENING MONOLOGUE.
♫
♫ ♫
SO IT BEGINS, REMEMBER JUST A
FEW MONTHS AGO DURING THE
MIDTERMS, I REPEATEDLY WARNED
YOU, PRETTY MUCH EVERY NIGHT
ABOUT WHAT TO THE DEMOCRATS WERE
REAL BUT HIDDEN AGENDA WAS.
THE AGENDA THAT THEY WERE HIDING
BEFORE THE ELECTION.
THEY WANT TO IMPEACH THE
PRESIDENT, THEY WANT OPEN
BORDERS, GET RID OF ICE AND WANT
THEIR CRUMBS BACK AT
DESPERATELY, MORE REGULATIONS
AND ENDLESS NONSTOP
INVESTIGATION INTO ALL THINGS
DONALD TRUMP AND HIS
ADMINISTRATION.
NOW EVERY NIGHT AS WE GO OVER
THE NEWS, I WANT YOU TO LOOK AT
THINGS FROM A DIFFERENT
PERSPECTIVE.
AS WE TALK TO THE NEW NEWSMAKERS
ON THE DEMOCRATIC SIDE.
ASK YOURSELF VERY IMPORTANT
QUESTIONS BECAUSE YOU ARE GOING
TO COME TO A CONCLUSION PRETTY
QUICKLY, I THINK.
ARE THOSE IN POWER THAT WE SHOW
YOU EVERY NIGHT -- ASK YOURSELF,
IF WHAT THEY ARE DOING IS GOOD
FOR THIS COUNTRY.
TO DO THEIR COMMENTS, DO THEIR
REMARKS, DREW THEIR ACTIONS, DO
THEY STRENGTHEN THE COUNTRY?
WILL WHAT THEY ARE DOING IMPROVE
THE LIVES OF THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE?
HELP THE AMERICAN PEOPLE?
ADVANCE OUR COUNTRY, OUR
COUNTRY’S INTEREST.
YOU CAN FORGET ABOUT A RED
STATE, BLUE STATE, DEMOCRAT,
REPUBLICAN, CONSERVATIVE,
LIBERAL, IS WHAT YOU’RE SEEING
GOOD FOR THE UNITED STATES OF
AMERICA AND THE AMERICAN PEOPLE?
BECAUSE AS WE SPEAK, THERE ARE
SOME IN THIS COUNTRY THAT ARE SO
FILLED WITH ANTI-TRUMP RAGE
EVERY SECOND, EVERY MINUTE,
EVERY HOUR OF EVERY DAY THAT
THEY ARE WILLING TO SAY AND TO
DO ANYTHING TO DESTROY THE
PRESIDENT, HIS FAMILY,
DELEGITIMIZE THE 2016 ELECTION,
EVEN IF AMERICA AND WE THE
PEOPLE SUFFER AS A RESULT.
MANY MONTHS AGO I IDENTIFIED
WHAT I CALL THE FIVE FORCES THAT
ARE ACTIVELY WORKING AGAINST THE
PRESIDENT.
OBVIOUSLY IT IS DEMOCRATS, THEY
HATE HIM.
THEN YOU HAVE THE ESTABLISHMENT
MEDIA, THEY HATE HIM.
NEVER-TRUMPERS THEY WANT TO NOT
BE A PART IN ELECTING SOMEBODY
WHO HAS GOVERNED CONSERVATIVELY.
ESTABLISH REPUBLICANS THAT ARE
WEAK.
AND THE DEEP STATE.
THE EMPEROR ALMOST TWO YEARS
THEY HAVE BEEN TOTALLY OBSESSED
AS WE ALL KNOW BY NOW RUSSIA,
RUSSIA, RUSSIA WITH A FEW
INTERMITTENT DISTRACTIONS LIKE
STORMING, STORMING, WHATEVER
ELSE.
BUT ON FRIDAY THE FIVE FORCES
SUFFERED A SETBACK WHEN THE
MEMOS ON PAUL MANAFORT, MICHAEL
COHEN INDICATED NO, NONE, NO
EVIDENCE OF ANY TRUMP-RUSSIA
COLLUSION.
A ZERO.
TAXICAB MEDALLIONS, LOAN
APPLICATIONS, TAXES IN GENERAL.
NOTHING ABOUT RUSSIA OR TRUMP.
THE FORCES WERE KIND OF
DISTRAUGHT, SO THEY SENT THEIR
SELVES INTO THE PREDICTABLE
CONVULSIONS AND SETTLED ON
PLAN B, THEIR BACKUP PLAN,
IMAGINARY FINANCE CAMPAIGN
PLANS, THAT’S WHAT THE RUSSIA
COLLUSION WAS ABOUT TO READ AND
THEN IN THE SAD AND HATE FILLED
WORLD, MICHAEL COHEN’S GUILTY
PLEA MAKING THE ILLEGAL
CONTRIBUTIONS WILL SURELY RESULT
IN THE END OF PRESIDENT TRUMP
ONCE AND FOR ALL.
OR SO THEY SAY.
LET’S TAKE A LOOK AT THE
MANUFACTURED BUT PREDICTABLE
HYSTERIA.
>> THIS IS A MAN THAT STATEMENT
ONLY MAX SAID THAT I AM BIGGER
THAN THE HOUSE, BIGGER THAN FREE
PRESS.
AND HE IS ONLY GOING TO PASTE
THAT FOR THE REST OF HIS LIFE.
>> WHEN IMMIGRANTS PROCURE THEIR
CITIZENSHIP BY FRAUD, WE STRIP
THEM OF THEIR SEDATIVES THEIR
CITIZENSHIP, WHEN A PRESIDENT
PROCURES HIS
PRESIDENCY, SHOULD WE CONSIDER D
PRESIDENCY, SHOULD WE CONSIDER I
PRESIDENCY, SHOULD WE CONSIDER G
THE SAME?
>> I THINK THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
WOULD SUPPORT IMPEACHMENT.
>> DONALD TRUMP MUST BE, WILL BE
IMPEACHED.
>> HE HAS TO KNOW THAT HIS
FUTURE LOOKS LIKE IT IS BEHIND
BARS.
>> DONALD TRUMP IS A CRIMINAL
ENTERPRISE.
>> IT CERTAINLY LOOKS LIKE THEY
ARE THE KIND OF OFFENSES THAT
WOULD CALL FOR IMPEACHMENT
HEARINGS.
>> YOU HAVE THIS MEMORABLE
PHRASE OF INDIVIDUAL NUMBER ONE,
AND IT WILL GO DOWN IN THE
HISTORY BOOKS ALONG WITH SOME OF
THE MEMORABLE WATERGATE PHRASES.
THE MEMORABLE WATERGATE PHRASES.>> HE MAY BE THE FIRST PRESIDENT
>> HE MAY BE THE FIRST PRESIDENT
IN QUITE SOME TIME TO FACE THE
PROSPECT OF JAIL TIME.
>> WHEN EVIDENCE BECOME SO CLEAR
THAT YOU’RE VERY LIKELY HAVE A
CRIMINAL SITTING IN THE
OVAL OFFICE, WHAT IS THE
CONGRESS LEFT TO DO AT THAT
POINT?
>> Sean: THESE ARE THE SAME
PEOPLE THAT HAVE BEEN SAYING THE
SAME LIES FOR YEARS AND IT IS
UNFOUNDED ACCORDING TO FOX NEWS
LEGAL ANALYST, GREGG JARRETT, IF
THE NONDISCLOSURE PAYMENT TO
STORMY DANIELS OR ANYBODY ELSE
SERVED A SECONDARY PURPOSE OR
DUAL-PURPOSE, THEN IT IS NOT
CONSIDERED A CAMPAIGN
CONTRIBUTION AND THUS NOT
ILLEGAL.
IN OTHER WORDS HAVE THE PAYMENT
BENEFITED THE TRUMP
ORGANIZATION, THE TRUMP BRAND
NAME, EVEN PRESIDENT TRUMP ON A
PERSONAL OR FAMILY LEVEL, THAT
IS NOT AGAINST THE LAW.
IT IS AS SIMPLE AS THAT.
AND THE PRESIDENT SUMMED IT UP
PRETTY PERFECTLY ON TWITTER
WRITING "THERE WAS NO COLLUSION,
SO NOW THE DEMOCRATS GO TO A
SIMPLE PRIVATE TRANSACTION.
CALLING IT A CAMPAIGN
CONTRIBUTION, WHICH IT WAS NOT,
BUT EVEN IF IT WAS, IT IS ONLY A
CIVIL CASE LIKE OBAMA’S, BUT IT
WAS DONE CORRECTLY BY A LAWYER.
AND THERE WOULD NOT BE A FINE,
LAWYER’S LIABILITY IF HE MADE A
MISTAKE, NOT ME.
COHEN TRYING TO GET HIS SENTENCE
REDUCED, WHICH HUNT."
REMEMBER THAT COHEN CHANGED HIS
STORY ON THE ISSUE, AND IT IS
FASCINATING, BECAUSE THE LIBERAL
MEDIA AND THE DEMOCRATS ONLY
WANT TO PICK THE VERSION THAT
FITS THEIR DESIRE POLITICAL
GOAL.
THEY DID NOT BELIEVE HIM THE
FIRST TIME.
EVEN INITIALLY STATED THAT THE
DANIELS PAYMENT FOR EXAMPLE CAME
OUT OF HIS OWN POCKET WITHOUT
THE PRESIDENT’S KNOWLEDGE, AND
SADLY MOST OF HIS ALLEGED CRIMES
DO INCLUDE LYING AND FRAUD.
BUT THE MEDIA WANTS TO BELIEVE
COHEN NOW.
THEY DO NOT LIKE MICHAEL COHEN.
THEY HAVE NEVER LIKED MICHAEL
COHEN.
AND THEY ARE NOT HIS FRIEND
TODAY.
MEANWHILE THE PRESIDENT HAS
ACTED IN ACCORDANCE WITH THE LAW
ACTED IN ACCORDANCE WITH THE LA
LAW.
WITH NO CRIMINAL FINANCE
VIOLATION AND SURE AS HELL NEVER
COLLUDED WITH RUSSIA WHICH IS
WHAT THIS WAS SUPPOSED TO BE
ABOUT.
BUT THEN DISGRUNTLED DIRECTOR
JAMES COMEY, NEVER LETTING
INNOCENCE GET IN THE WAY OF HIS
COMPLETE AND TOTAL OBSESSIVE
HATRED FOR PRESIDENT TRUMP.
HE CALLED ON AMERICANS TO OUST
PRESIDENT TRUMP WITH "EVERY
BREATH WE HAVE."
BUT HE IS NOT BIAS AT ALL, TAKE
A LOOK.
>> ALL OF US SHOULD USE EVERY
BREATH WE HAVE TO MAKE SURE THAT
THE LINE STOPS.
ON JANUARY 20TH, 2021.
>> Tucker: I GUESS HE DOES NOT
HAVE A POLITICAL AGENDA, THE
SAME GUY THAT LEAD TO
INFORMATION TO GET ROBERT MUELLR
APPOINTED.
OH, THAT IS THE SAME COMEY WHO
MIGHT HAVE ESPIONAGE ISSUES
HIMSELF BY RELEASING THOSE
DOCUMENTS IN THE SAME GUY THAT
WELL, MAY BE IN TROUBLE HIMSELF
WITH THE LAW.
I HAVE SOME ADVICE FOR JIM
COMEY, DO NOT THROW STONES FROM
A GLASS HOUSE, IT IS DECEMBER,
BUT THE YEAR OF THE BOOMERANG IS
NOT QUITE OVER.
LATE LAST WEEK COMEY TESTIFIED
BEHIND CLOSED DOORS ON
CAPITOL HILL ABOUT THE MULTIPLE
CONTROVERSIES WITH HIS
LEADERSHIP AT THE FBI INCLUDING
FISA ABUSE, HIS HANDLING OF THE
CLINTON INVESTIGATION FOR A MAN
THAT CLAIMS TO HAVE SUCH
INTEGRITY AND GREAT MEMORY.
HE SEEMED TO HAVE A REALLY HARD
TIME ANSWERING QUESTIONS OR
REMEMBERED ANYTHING THE MATTER,
MANY ACCUSED HIM OF USING HIS
ATTORNEY IS TO RUN INTERFERENCE
WHILE ANOTHER 245 TIMES
HE SAYS HE CANNOT REMEMBER.
>> THE REPUBLICANS CAME OUT AND
SAID THAT A GOVERNMENT LAWYER
RAN THE INTERFERENCE IN SIGNS OF
A SHUTDOWN OF SPECIFIC MINES,
DID THAT HAPPEN?
IF SO WHAT TOPICS WERE NOT
DISCUSSED?
>> ONE, YOU READ THE TRANSCRIPTS
AND I THINK YOU WILL SEE THAT
NOT HAPPENING.
>> Sean: HE DID ADMIT THAT THE
STEELE DOSSIER WAS NEVER
VERIFIED.
WE WILL GET TO THAT IN A SECOND.
ANOTHER LIE FROM JAMES COMEY,
THE TRANSCRIPT WAS OUT,
HAPPENING OVER AND OVER AND OVER
AGAIN, 250 TIMES ACCORDING TO
TREY GOWDY, HE ANSWERED, I DON’T
RECALL 71 TIMES, HE STATED I
DON’T KNOW AN ADDITIONAL 166
TIMES.
ONE LAWMAKER REPORTEDLY SAID
"HIS MEMORY WAS SO BAD I FEAR
THAT HE MIGHT NOT REMEMBER
HAVING -- HOW TO GET OUT OF THE
ROOM AFTER THE INTERVIEW.
IT WAS LIKE HE SUDDENLY
DEVELOPED ALZHEIMER’S AFTER
CONVENIENTLY REMEMBERING ENOUGH
FACTS TO SELL HIS BOOK.
PRETTY AWFUL PAID A LOT OF
SELECTIVE AMNESIA FROM SOMEBODY
WHO CLAIMS TO BE AN INNOCENT
MAN.
BUT EVEN MORE TROUBLING IS THIS.
SOMETHING THAT COMEY ACTUALLY
SAID DURING THE HEARING.
ACCORDING TO THE TRANSCRIPT FROM
FRIDAY, HE ADMITTED THAT HILLARY
IT’S BOUGHT AND PAID FOR DIRTY
RUSHING DOSSIER, THE ONE THAT
WAS USED TO COMMIT A FRAUD FOUR
SEPARATE OCCASIONS ON FISA
COURTS WAS NEVER VERIFIED EITHER
BEFORE OR AFTER THE FISA WARRANT
APPLICATION.
LET ME EXPLAIN THIS.
IN OTHER WORDS, THE FBI AND THE
DOJ HAD ZERO IDEA IF WHAT THEY
WERE USING TO GET ONE OF THE
HARDEST WARRANTS TO GET, A FISA
WARRANT, ZERO CLUE WHETHER ANY
OF THE EVIDENCE WAS CREDIBLE.
TRUE, AND COOPERATED, WHICH BY
LAW AND BY A PROTOCOL MUST
HAPPEN AS A MATTER OF COURSE.
THEY SPIED ON AN AMERICAN
CITIZEN, TRAMPLED ON HIS FOURTH
A TRUMP CAMPAIGN ASSOCIATE WITH
AMENDMENT CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHTS.
INFORMATION PAID FOR BY THE
CLINTON CAMPAIGN AND THE DNC
THAT WE NOW KNOW IS COMPLETELY
AND TOTALLY UNVERIFIED.
BUT WAIT, DIDN’T ROD ROSENSTEIN
OR SALLY YATES, WHO SIGNED OFF,
SIGNING OFF ON THE FINAL FISA
APPLICATION, IDENTITY SAY THAT
LAW ENFORCEMENT IF THEY ARE
GOING TO SIGN A FISA WARRANT,
IDENTITY SAY THAT THAT OFFICER
MUST WEAR THAT THE INFORMATION
IN THE FISA REQUEST IS TRUE AND
ACCURATE?
AND IF HE GOT IT WRONG, THERE
WERE SERIOUS CONSEQUENCES.
I KNOW, BECAUSE I HAVE THE TAPE.
>> THERE IS A LOT OF TALK ABOUT
FISA APPLICATIONS.
MANY PEOPLE THAT I SEE YOU
TALKING ABOUT IT SEEM NOT TO
RECOGNIZE WHAT A FISA
APPLICATION -- A FISA
APPLICATION IS ACTUALLY A
WARRANT JUST LIKE A SEARCH
WARRANT, IN ORDER TO GET A FISA
SEARCH WARRANT, YOU NEED AN
AFFIDAVIT SIGNED BY A CAREER
FEDERAL LAW ENFORCEMENT OFFICER
WHO SWEARS THAT THE INFORMATION
IN THE AFFIDAVIT IS TRUE AND
CORRECT TO THE BEST OF HIS
KNOWLEDGE AND BELIEF.
AND THAT IS THE WAY THAT WE
OPERATE.
IF YOU FIND OUT THAT THAT THERE
IF IT IS WRONG, SOMETIMES IT IS,
IS ANYTHING INCORRECT, THAT
PERSON WILL FACE CONSEQUENCES.
>> Sean: COMEY WILL FACE
CONSEQUENCES.
JUST WAITING TO FIND OUT WHAT
THEY WERE.
IN AMERICAN WAS SPIED ON BY YOUR
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT, THINK ABOUT
THIS WITH A WARRANT BASED ON
WHAT WAS ON COOPERATED,
UNVERIFIED, OPPOSITION RESEARCH,
BOUGHT AND PAID FOR IT LIES BY
HILLARY CLINTON.
AND THEY NEVER TOLD THE JUDGE
THAT HILLARY PAID FOR IT.
EVER.
MULTIPLE JUDGES WERE LIED TO.
MULTIPLE FRAUDS WERE COMMITTED
ON THE FISA COURT.
WHEN WILL WE HEAR FROM THE FISA
JUDGES?
BECAUSE THOSE WOULD BE CRIMES IN
ALL LIKELIHOOD, OUR OWN
GREGG JARRETT HAS IDENTIFIED SIX
SPECIFIC FELONIES THAT WOULD BE
APPLICABLE ON THIS CASE ALONE.
NOW IF THE LEFT REALLY CARED
ABOUT CIVIL LIBERTIES, THEY
WOULD BE DEMANDING AN
INVESTIGATION.
THEY WOULD CARE ABOUT EQUAL
JUSTICE UNDER THE LAW, EQUAL
APPLICATION OF OUR LAWS, AND OUR
CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHTS.
BUT LIKE WITH EVERYTHING ELSE,
THE DESTROY-TRUMP FORCES ARE
WILLING TO PUT ALL OF THEIR
HATRED FOR THE PRESIDENT ABOVE
EVERYTHING ELSE, FOR THEM IT IS
ALWAYS POLITICS IT IS THE
VERY REASON THEY TRIED
TO RUIN JUSTICE KAVANAUGH’S LIFE
WITHOUT ANY DUE PROCESS WITHOUT
ANY PRESUMPTION OF INNOCENCE ON
A CASE THAT HAVE BEEN 36 YEARS
PRIOR.
BUT AT THE SAME TIME THEY BARELY
GONE, SAID NOTHING OVER RECENT
ABUSE ALLEGATIONS, PHYSICAL,
EMOTIONAL, AGAINST KEITH
ELLISON, THE NUMBER OF TWO AT
THE DNC.
MANY OF THE SAME PEOPLE OF
BILL CLINTON.
NONE OF THEM SPOKE OUT ABOUT
MICHAEL AVENATTI.
IF YOU ARE A DEMOCRAT, YOU DO
NOT GET THE KAVANAUGH TREATMENT.
THAT IS A VERY REASON WHY THEY
OBSESS ABOUT RUSSIA, RUSSIA FOR
YEARS, BUT THEY IGNORE THE
URANIUM ONE SCANDAL.
WHERE VLADIMIR PUTIN HAD A
NETWORK INSIDE THIS COUNTRY.
THE FOUNDATIONAL MATERIAL OF
NUCLEAR WEAPONS, FOR CRYING OUT
LOUD.
20% OF AMERICA’S FOUNDATIONAL
MATERIAL FOR NUCLEAR WEAPONS.
PUTIN NETWORK IN AMERICA, WE
HAVE A SPY IN THERE.
THAT IS CHRONICLING ROBBERY,
KICKBACKS, MONEY LAUNDERING,
EXTORTION.
AND HE IS TELLING THE FBI, THEN
ROBERT MUELLER, BUT THE DEAL
STILL WENT THROUGH, HILLARY
APPROVED IT.
AND GUESS WHAT, HER FOUNDATION
ENDED UP WITH PEOPLE INVOLVED IN
THAT DEAL $145 MILLION.
GIVEN TO THE CLINTON FOUNDATION.
AND YES, SOME OF THAT URANIUM
LEFT THE UNITED STATES PAID
WHERE’S THE OUTRAGE OVER THAT
SERIOUS RUSSIA SCANDAL?
WHY WOULD WE EVER ALLOW PUTIN’S
THUGS IN AMERICA TO GET A HOLD
OF OUR URANIUM AND WE DO NOT
HAVE ENOUGH URANIUM AS A
COUNTRY?
WHERE’S THAT INVESTIGATION?
AND IN THE CASE OF HILLARY’S
DIRTY DOSSIER, SAME HERE.
2016, THE CAMPAIGN FUNNELED
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS, OH, THREE
LAW FORM, I BET IF PAUL MANAFORT
OR MICHAEL COHEN DID IT THEY
WOULD BE ARRESTED.
BUT ANYWAY, LOSING A RESEARCH
FIRM, HIRING A FOREIGN NATIONAL
WHO USES QUESTIONABLE STIES
SPIES FROM RUSSIA, CHRISTOPHER
STEELE PUTTING TOGETHER RESEARCH
FROM RUSSIA.
THE DOSSIER IS BASED ON RUSSIAN
LIES PAID FOR BY HILLARY, AND I
THOUGHT WE WERE INVESTIGATING
RUSSIAN INFLUENCE ON THE
ELECTION.
NO INVESTIGATION INTO BOUGHT AND
PAID FOR LIES TO INFLUENCE THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE.
SO YOU THINK ABOUT THIS WHEN YOU
TURN ON THESE OTHER NETWORKS OR
PICK UP A NEWSPAPER.
YOU THINK ABOUT THIS IF YOU
LISTEN TO ANY DEMOCRAT ACROSS
THIS COUNTRY AND THEIR
SANCTIMONY, AND THEIR LECTURERS
TALKING ABOUT CAMPAIGN FINANCE,
THERE IS NO TRUMP-RUSSIA
COLLUSION.
BUT WE HAVE MAJOR, MAJOR
MISTAKES.
LET’S SEE, VLADIMIR PUTIN, TELL